EVERETT BERRYMAN, JR: I have
been reluctant to tell them
my story because a
lot of the youngsters
did not experience
what I experienced.
They didn't go through
what I went through.
My experience here
was to be locked out.
ABBY PHILLIP: In 1954, the
landmark Supreme Court case
Brown v. Board of
Education established
that racial segregation
of public schools
was unconstitutional.
The case made a
little girl named
Linda Brown from
Topeka, Kansas the face
of school desegregation.
But like many fights of
the Civil Rights era,
the story begins far
earlier than that.
CAMERON PATTERSON:
When you think
of what happens here
in Prince Edward,
it's prior to the
Montgomery bus boycotts.
It's prior to the
Selma-to-Montgomery
voting rights marches.
And I don't think you can talk
about the modern Civil Rights
movement without
understanding what happens
here in Prince Edward County.
LARISSA SMITH: The
facilities of Black schools
were generally inferior to
white schools at the time.
ABBY PHILLIP: One
of those schools
was the all-Black Robert
Russa Moton High School
in Prince Edward County,
Virginia, where a museum
bearing its name now stands.
The school was built
for 180 students.
But by 1951, it was
bursting with over 450.
Some classes were
held in an old school
bus, others in tar-paper rooms
heated with potbelly stoves.
The students staged
a walkout that year,
launching a two-week strike
and demanding the school board
build a bigger, better school.
CAMERON PATTERSON:
This student walkout
would lead to a local court
case, Davis versus County
School Board at Prince Edward.
And that Davis case would
combine with cases from four
other communities to make
up what we would know
as Brown v. Board of Education.
ABBY PHILLIP: The
Brown ruling in 1954
was supposed to radically alter
education for Black children.
But white populations
across the South
almost immediately fought
against its implementation,
none more so than in
Prince Edward County, where
that student walkout
helped propel the Brown
case to the Supreme Court.
The county closed, at
least 20 public schools
from 1959 to 1964, denying
upwards of 1,500 students
an education for five years.
Historians regard it as one of
the fiercest acts of resistance
against school desegregation.
So what happened to the
students, the Black students
and the white students?
DAWN WILLIAMS: The
White Citizens' Council,
within the community,
created a school,
created a school that
was a private school
that opened up in Prince Edward
County just for white children.
For the Black
community, there were
no forms of public schooling.
My family, who did not
have a lot of resources,
were a part of that
segment of the community
that did without formal
schooling for that time period.
LARISSA SMITH: Civil rights
groups came into the county
and helped to set up
makeshift schools that
were called training centers.
Black women organized grassroots
schools in their homes.
DAWN WILLIAMS: So
imagine being a mom,
and you have a school-age
child, and you send your child
away to another
family that you don't
know just so that your
child can get the education.
EVERETT BERRYMAN, JR: We
basically moved into the house
with the family.
The first family they
didn't have any children.
The second family had children,
but it was really a big house.
They had about four children,
and five more came in.
And we still could get lost
in the house, so to speak.
ABBY PHILLIP: And it didn't
only impact the students.
The Black teachers
in the community
lost their jobs as well.
ELLIOTT BROWN PALMER, SR: I
had to spend day and night
traveling over this state
following behind complaints
of Black teachers being
dismissed where schools
were being desegregated.
They tried to say, we
don't want Black teachers
teaching white students.
DAWN WILLIAMS: Teaching at
that time was a profession
that was heavily lauded.
It was a profession
highly respected,
particularly within
the Black community.
ABBY PHILLIP: In fact,
nationwide tens of thousands
of Black teachers
lost their jobs
as an unanticipated consequence
of Brown v. Board of Education.
Taken together, the vanishing
of Black teacher jobs
and the school closings
dramatically affected
lives across the county.
One estimate found that
illiteracy rates of Blacks ages
5 to 22 jumped from 3% to
23% in those five years,
even as the push for
desegregation continued.
A pending court case
was amended in 1961
to challenge private school tax
breaks given to white families.
As that case, Griffin versus
County School Board of Prince
Edward County, was making
its way to the Supreme Court,
the Justice
Department stepped in,
encouraged by a
broader civil rights
movement sweeping the South.
It spearheaded efforts to create
a free schools program in 1963
for all children
in the community.
LARISSA SMITH: And they
really are interested
in what's happening here in
Prince Edward because they
understand that if a county
cannot fund its public schools
and shut them down and get away
with it, then Brown would be
a dead letter across the South.
ABBY PHILLIP: And a year
later, the Supreme Court
ruled on the Griffin
case, ordering all schools
in the county to
reopen and declaring
the time for mere deliberate
speed has run out.
When Everett R.
Berryman, Jr. eventually
graduated from Moton
high school in 1967,
the schools were
still mostly Black.
EVERETT BERRYMAN, JR:
The whole experience,
when I look back on it, helped
me to get to where I am today.
Actually, it caused me
to step up to the plate
and to find myself.
And once I found myself,
then I could go on forward.
ABBY PHILLIP: Today,
the public school system
is 65% students of color, a
hard-earned legacy of the fight
to implement the Brown mandate.
But so too are the unmistakable
remnants of the racial divide.
The private school that
was founded in 1959
during the school
closures is still there,
and it remains
overwhelmingly white.
And those students
of color now sit
in public school classrooms.
More than half of them are
economically disadvantaged.
One historian attributes the
poor adult literacy rates,
in part, to those
lost five years,
when over 1,000 Black students
were denied an education.
Progress, it turns out,
is complicated to define.
ELLIOTT BROWN PALMER, SR: Many
of us speak of the Brown era
as if it's all over with.
It isn't all over with.
It's still going on,
in one form or another.